Today's show is brought to you by audible.
Please visit audible.com/bill for your free audio book download.
Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March 11th,
2013.
How you doing?
How's your life working out for you this week?
I,
um,
I had a fall.
Jesus,
you know what?
I can't even tell you what happened.
I can't tell it.
I have to sing it to you.
It's got to come from my heart.
Oh.
If you're a lucky man,
good things happen to you.
But if you're a red cunt,
this is full of fucking zoo.
You'll be out on the road and find out your roof collapsed and there won't be a
thing you can do about it.
That make any sense.
I don't care if it did.
You know,
most of the,
some of the biggest hits never made any sense.
Right?
Oh,
sugar,
boop,
boop.
You are ma can d girl.
Um,
so I was touring the Midwest barnstorming as they say,
driving and some no name dodge SUV.
You know,
that's what you get when you say,
hey,
I want to rent a car from Madison,
Wisconsin to Detroit,
Michigan,
and I don't want to bring it back.
Do you have a car for me?
And they say,
Oh,
why?
You know what?
I think we got one here in the back.
I didn't even know dodge made an SUV.
You know,
dodge is like the Oldsmobile of Chrysler.
Um,
automobiles are nice.
I like,
I,
you know,
I miss all those cars that were going to be Oldsmobile,
man.
When people had a mercury,
what else did they discontinue?
Pontiac's what has happened to this country?
What have you bet did Dan,
do you get a Chevy or Cadillac that's fucking it.
Ford or a Lincoln?
Go Fuck Yourself.
You know,
you either have it or you don't.
Once again,
another side of the middle class shrinking.
Um,
oh by the way,
you know,
I just found out,
cause I don't pay attention to politics anymore because I just feel like,
all right,
you know,
they're there eventually just they're gonna run it into the ground.
We're gonna have to build it back up again.
That's,
that's basically what's going to happen.
I guess.
Sola all a fucking liberal face there.
He signed that thing,
new years eve basically passing off it.
Now they can just arrest you and detain you without a trial forever.
That's good.
There you go.
See that right there people.
Everyone.
You all made fun of me cause I don't vote for the fucking number one horse and
number two horse.
That's why,
cause there's no difference.
It's the same fucking horse.
Oh,
shut up bill.
All right,
so this is what happened.
So I'm fucking driving this,
no name,
DOJ driving this dodge SUV.
I'm in Madison,
Wisconsin and um,
baret do all these awesome shows.
I love going to towns like that.
By the way,
I can tell you this unbelievably is cities that uh,
Frank Sinatra did not sing about,
you know,
or Tony Bennet,
any,
any crooner.
If a crooner has sung about a city,
then you can tell right away that,
you know,
before you even land on the ground is going to be ridiculous traffic and
everything's going to cost twice as much.
You know,
Ma,
I kind of town Chicago is $80 for a hamburger.
Chicago is that fucking loop where no traffic fucking move,
right?
I left my hat and San Francisco,
that new fucking wall and then New York,
you know what that is,
right?
Bunch of fucking losers was stenciled goatees and sweatpants thinking they're
fucking,
they're,
they're making it.
If I can wake up in a city,
right,
and it's sitting there shirtless,
riding in a fuck,
and you go that they cut the roof off of putting their hands in the air as they
drive through fucking times square,
making a video for their rockabilly album.
You know,
all of those places.
I'm not saying he shouldn't go there.
You should definitely go there.
Right?
And bring your easel and do a little sketch or whatever the fuck it is you're
supposed to do.
But I'm telling you,
don't sleep on Madison,
Wisconsin.
Don't you dare look down on Milwaukee,
Wisconsin,
and I'll tell you right now,
I've got another one for you.
This is the uppercut grand rapids,
Michigan.
Yeah.
Where are you guys going on vacation?
You're going to Puerto Rico.
You going to Aco Poco?
No,
we're going to grand rapids,
Michigan and we're going to get some fucking,
I'm going to go get a waffle,
which at the a,
the real food cafe.
I ate like a fucking suicidal plumber this week.
At least the breakfast I had a waffle,
which when I was in grand rapids,
Michigan.
Oh,
Royal Oak Michigan.
I also forgot about that and I'll tell you,
downtown Detroit slowly coming back the outskirts is still pretty scary,
but I got to tell you,
you know they have pockets.
You know there's a gleam gentlemen.
There is a gleam,
worst fucking pre play off.
I think I talked about that speech ever.
Marty Schottenheimer,
he's trying to get his team amped up to win a playoff game.
That standing on that fucking football,
whether we can see your breath,
you know,
and as they're looking at his breath,
in his breath it says there's a gentlemen,
a gleam gleam has never been spoken in football ever.
You know,
if you,
in fact,
if you have a gleam,
I think at this point,
that's one of the reasons why you get cut from a football team.
Why didn't you get once you get rid of him?
I thought he was doing all right on us.
Special teams.
Ah,
there was a gleam and it was a gleam gentlemen and I didn't like it.
I didn't see that killer instinct.
He was too gleamy
yes.
This podcast isn't going to make any sense cause fucking brain is all over the
place cause I have a hole in the roof of my house.
I will get to that.
Okay.
I will get to that and you will sit and you will wait.
Cancer.
So anyways,
I'm in Madison,
Wisconsin,
you know,
and uh,
I was working with Nate Craig and he's from that neck of the woods,
actually grew up right near there.
So he was taking me around town,
went to all these great places to eat.
Went to the some legendary breakfast place,
one of those greasy spoons that somebody who's running for president stops in
at,
you know,
has two bites of eggs,
does a thumbs up with some fucking immigrant wearing an apron and then he
leaves.
Well,
I actually stayed there and I ate the whole breakfast and I'm not running for
anything,
you know?
Um,
Oh God,
I'm so fat right now.
Yeah.
You can't believe how smooth my stomach is.
My stomach right now is so fucking smooth.
You wouldn't even believe that I could sit up in bed because you would say that
poor bastard was born without abdomens abs,
abdominals.
There's the fucking word.
So anyways,
um,
we do the GIG.
Okay.
We do the Gig.
Uh,
okay.
What the fuck was it?
I don't even know anymore.
Was it Thursday?
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
No.
Wednesday we do the Gig.
Wayne State.
We have a great fucking time after the Gig.
This guy from the weary traveler in rest slash restaurant tells us to come by.
We go over there.
I look on the menu.
What do they have on the menu?
They have Hungarian Goulash.
When was the last time you ever saw a Hungarian fucking Goulash or the rated g
version?
Hungarian Goulash on a,
on a menu.
Huh?
Well,
if you do then you live with one of these fucking towns that frank never sung
about.
And I was like,
my mother used to make Hungarian Goulash.
I got it.
I got to try it.
Okay.
Um,
then I guess when my mother made it,
when my mother,
when she made it,
she put noodles in it.
But this was the,
I guess that,
that the noodles came in in Ellis island.
Well,
did you have a dental?
He meant the Hungarians were near the Italians and they were like,
oh,
what she got in the pot there?
You know what you need step is I want you to put some fucking noodles in there
right there.
All right,
there is it?
Danoe.
So anyways,
I had this,
this Cup of,
uh,
if you're in Madison,
Wisconsin,
go,
I'm going to type all these fucking restaurants,
go to the weary traveler in and try a cup or get yourself a bowl of the
Hungarian Goulash is fine.
It's fucking tremendous.
It's got a nice kick to it.
You know,
I visited it a couple of old friends,
you know,
with ice on him and I had a great time and uh,
great mix of people there.
We talked conspiracy theory,
we talked about Wes Welker getting traded,
you know,
we had an awesome fucking time,
so everything's going great.
You know,
I'm breathing in the winter air looking at the dirty snow.
I'm feeling good.
I'm feeling like nothing can touch me.
My life is going to be phenomenal.
All right.
Now the next thing that happened on this trip is so fucking traumatic.
I don't really remember when it started.
I believe I was coming out of that greasy diner that I'm sure Joe Biden is eaten
and um,
and with the pancakes are delicious.
Ha ha ha.
Click picture taken these out forces himself to puke
in the,
uh,
taxpayers busted.
He's driving around in,
um,
anyways,
the lovely Nia calls me up and she's an absolute tears.
All right.
We had just done,
redone her office.
We did the floors.
I swear to God,
dude,
it looked like a fucking basketball court in there.
A very small basketball court,
you know,
if you will like a fucking a squirrel,
it would look like a full court basketball court.
T all right,
but whatever.
I'm just saying it was fucking beautiful.
We did the walls,
they even painted the ceiling.
It was the one room in my old ass fucking house that was immaculate.
All right.
I just got the roof done.
Listeners of the podcast realize I just got the roof done.
So I'm psyched.
Cake is two things you don't want in your fucking house.
You don't want fire and you don't want water.
Nothing does damage like that.
It's just,
it's fucking over.
So
she calls me up crying and says the fucking ceiling collapsed in the office and
there's water pouring in
and um,
and I am in the middle of fucking nowhere.
Wisconsin.
I was in between somewhere between Madison and Milwaukee and I get this picture
and I get this phone call
and
how memetically frantic and I was like,
has the water stopped cause it can of rain that night.
And I'm like,
is the water stopped?
And I'm thinking,
we just put a new roof on it.
Did they fuck up the roof?
What the fuck happened?
A zillion things that going through my head.
How long was the water pouring in?
Because it happened when she was sleeping and then she goes,
no,
it stopped.
And then she went back and she goes,
no,
it started again.
And I was like fuck.
And you know,
she was talking about her pictures and shit.
And I'm like,
no,
the floors,
the fucking rest of the house get a,
I wish I'd thought to tell her to push the fucking couch.
We've got this stupid Ikea couch,
you know,
and you're not thinking,
he's just trying to get the furniture out away.
Fucking fuck the couch.
Let the couch be a giant fucking sponge.
Um,
well,
whatever.
I was in the middle of nowhere.
And uh,
what ended up happening was it wasn't the roof.
I have a crawl space between my ceiling and the roof.
And there was some,
you know,
my house is like 90 years old.
So there was some sort of part of the drainage things.
One of the joints failed.
It backed up on the side of the house and the water came up and then one of the
joints failed and then it just started to pool.
It's sunk down to the wood and then,
you know,
made the plaster wet and then it collapsed.
And um,
she didn't hear it collapsed because it kind of hit the couch was also fucking
soaking wet and uh,
the damage was done and it went all the way down to the bottom of my fucking
house.
And my house looks like a disaster right now.
Uh,
but I got to say the insurance company did step up once they realized that it
wasn't a his fault and that it was a plumbing issue or whatever,
the,
I don't know what the fuck they said.
Um,
they have stepped up and they came over here to fucking help the lovely Neil
clean up.
They put some fans on it,
but by then the fucking damage was done.
So I don't know what's going to happen.
I'm absolutely sick right now because they're trying to tell me that the floor
buckled.
Um,
and I immediately pictured all the floorboards,
just every one of them just fucking looking like hammer toes.
But I think they're trying to say it's in the middle of the room.
I don't know what,
but that would is priceless.
You know,
that's the wood that they from trees,
they cut down on the 20s that were,
you know,
old trees when wood was solid men,
what men and women didn't have a voice.
Now you've got that Home Depot Shit,
you know,
I should make he's cheese,
yo kind of wood.
Right?
So that's my big fear is that they're going to take out that wood and replace it
with the other shit.
So I've already put the Kibosh on that.
And I'm like,
listen,
uh,
insurance people,
that's the kind of wood that was there.
And that's the kind of wood this can be put down.
If I have to fucking scour the earth to find it.
Five to go to Detroit and go into one of those abandoned fucking crack house.
Beautiful hundred year old fucking houses.
And take the wood out myself.
I am a,
I don't want to get into it.
It's fucking horrible.
My brother's coming out to visit,
you know,
he's visited me like 20 times in my career.
In the first fucking 16,
I was sleeping on a futon.
The last three times I had a bed in a one bedroom apartment.
I finally have a fucking house,
right finally feeling like its success.
He's going to come and the fucking
fucking,
I was choking this week on stage that the hole in the ceiling,
it looked like.
Just imagine if for grizzly bears,
like parachute didn't open.
That was the size of the fucking hole.
And I don't know why.
Think grizzly bear,
I just remember seeing one fall out of a tree one time when they shot it with
something,
you know,
a tranquilizer gun and uh,
just Kinda came down.
It was like a big ball of fur.
That's what it looks like.
Maybe a,
maybe a black bear,
I'd say.
I don't know people,
you know,
the all time I bought this fucking house the entire time I've been fixed in this
fucking thing and it's all been shit.
You can't see plumbing,
electrical.
I don't even know what else to fucking roof.
Just Shit.
You can't see.
And I was finally getting to the fun part.
Shit,
you can see the floors,
right?
Should,
you can show off to people when they come over,
finally get a rum done.
And Mother Nature is like,
ah,
look at,
Oh Philly boy.
He thinks he's got a nice house there.
Let's,
let's,
let's do this man a fucking hole in your ceiling.
Do you like that?
You like dead?
Oh,
you want some more?
You want some more as a little fucking glass of water.
Deal with that all the way down to your basement.
All right,
day.
You're freckled cont how do you like that?
So
I've been absolutely,
uh,
I dunno,
you know,
just some,
it's,
you know,
what's a typical story?
Cyclical story,
man tries to do something.
It takes two steps forward,
gets kicked in the balls and falls,
three steps backwards.
Typical,
typical story.
And evidently there's going to be some comedy in this at some point,
but I realize it's tragedy plus time and I'm still in the middle of the fucking
tragedy.
Oh,
you know what else is great?
Cause the walls is so old.
This is in him,
you know,
like 1%.
So now the people who are going to take the plastic announced,
they are like little Wayne atray to do that.
We don't have the proper filter.
The anchor says that the level bumps and now they're out,
right?
They're looking at the shit downstairs.
They go,
oh we got to test for lead paint.
It's like it was made the twenties you know,
it has lead paint,
probably has 14 coats of it under fucking 36 that we'll paint it on top of that.
So,
uh,
God,
I,
I just,
you know,
I swear to God,
I swear to God first.
I hate to say this,
the first time ever I was in my garage today and I just,
and I actually quietly said to myself,
I hate this house.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
Do you guys say that about your kids?
Does that ever happen?
Every time you try to make your kid a better fucking citizen and every time you
think you fucking turned around the stupid fuck comes home,
you know,
got into a fight at school and got caught with a 12 pack or that they just like,
I just wish I never had that one just stopped at the other one.
I'll maybe skip this one.
I Dunno.
Anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast everybody and uh,
but you know something,
I am,
ah,
fuck it out.
I'll say something positive as secondly.
Let's get into the advertising.
I've got to hype something for a good buddy of my Wilsall Vince who was nice
enough,
um,
to be part of the,
the group of comics that helped to honor Patrice O'neil at the benefit we had.
And a will was one of Patrice has great friends and a roommate of his,
um,
God,
they lived together at least five,
six years.
So anyways,
we'll made some tee shirts.
We sold most of them I have to benefit.
He still has some left.
And I know a lot of people wanted to be a part of the benefit and he wants to
warn him to help out.
Uh,
Patrice has family.
Um,
maybe,
well,
here's your opportunity to get some limited edition for Teresa Neal tee shirts,
ones that are left.
Uh,
you can go to www dot.
I'm better than you.com,
and I'm better than you.
Uh,
the arm.
There's no,
uh,
fucking,
what is it?
An apostrophe,
whatever that thing is between the I and the M.
It's all one word.
All lowercase.
I'm better than you and you is spelled just the letter u.com.
We'll put the link up on the podcast page.
Um,
just know when you buy those that they're limited edition and also you'll be
given money to Teresa's,
uh,
his mother and his family.
All right,
they go.
So audible.com,
every bay,
everybody,
every day,
everybody
audible.
Audible is the Internet's leading provider of spoken audio entertainment
information and educational program.
Programming content from audible is downloaded and played back on personal
computers,
cds,
or iPod players.
Audible offers over 100,000 hours of audio programs from 270 content partners
that include leading audio book publishers,
broadcasters,
entertainers,
magazines and newspaper publishers,
podcasters,
and business information providers.
Listen to whenever and wherever you want.
Just like the podcast you're listening to right now,
audible has over 1000 science and technology,
okay.
And over one to 1100 science fiction and fantasy titles with more being added
all the time,
audible has over 100,000 titles to choose from every genre genre.
Audible,
I said covered.
Ah,
man,
I'm a moron.
Get a free audio book download when you sign up for a free trial today.
You know,
we should do that.
Me.
Maybe I'll be better at reading out loud.
Go to www.audible podcast.com/bill to get your free audio book today.
All right,
so there you go.
Well,
here's,
here's the positive thing that I take out of,
um,
out of what happened to me.
Oh,
here's one thing that you,
you know,
when your life is messed up,
something bad is happening to you is people bring up the fact that you're,
you're still have your health.
That's usually a good sign that something horrific happened to you.
But I'm actually seeing that story about that guy fucking dying in that sink
hole was one of the creepiest things I've ever seen in my life.
And I was like,
okay,
all right,
I'm sitting here crying about some wet floors and walls was a swallowed up by
the earth,
you know,
so I don't know.
I guess that's,
that's my positive way of looking at it.
By them bringing that horrific image into your head.
The fuck is wrong with me.
Um,
did I mentioned when I was in grand rapids,
Michigan,
I had a waffle,
which I did say that right.
What's a waffle which you ask?
It's a sandwich made out of a waffle with scrambled eggs and bacon and cheddar
cheese in the middle of it.
And I still think I'm paying for it,
but you know,
something,
it was delicious.
I got to tell you.
I did enjoy that waffle.
Which,
um,
you know what?
I'm not even gonna fuck around.
I'm getting it right.
Two emails here because this is something that's been bugging me.
Emails.
Red is dead,
Billy,
ready to shoes.
Uh,
they said that by 2060,
all redheads might be gone.
Also,
the Greeks believed redheads turned to vampires after they died.
Thanks and good luck.
All right.
The key word in that is they say,
I guess that's words.
They say that by 2060s,
by 2060,
all redheads might be gone.
Do you realize how fucking dumb you have to be to believe that
all redheads are going to be gone by 2060.
That's literally 47 years from now.
I mean,
granted by 20 in 2060 I'm going to turn 92.
I'm an old fuck right now.
I'm 45 years old this year.
By 2060,
I will be 92 years old,
but that's best possible mind if I keep eating waffle witches and have my house
collapsed on me.
I imagine that's going to take a toll.
All right?
For all you fucking morons out there who hear that in a bar or read it on the
Internet and you just keep repeating it without even thinking of what's coming
out of your mouth.
How many little red headed boys and girls,
if you seen go to the mall,
the fucking two,
three years old,
you're telling me they're all going to be dead before they are 50 you're dumb
fucks
this so fucking dumb.
Some asshole said it was a recessive gene and by the time it went around the
bar,
we were all going to be dead in 20 minutes and people are so fucking dumb and
they just repeat what they hear,
that they come at you and they say dumb shit like that.
Do you realize how many people have said that to me?
I mean at least this guy was smart enough to at least put it to twenties,
20,
60.
I mean,
look,
if we're all going to be gone,
we're fucking taken you converse with us because unless you guys just like,
if the next Hitler comes along and he just really hates fucking redheads and
starts to,
but even then there's going to be one of those Schindler list guys who's going
to make a list of his fucking redheads and we're going to survive.
Yeah.
Right.
And then we'll have a museum of tolerance for fucking redheads.
And then the history channel will slowly stop showing holocaust stuff and try
and balance it out and show some redhead genocide,
you know,
and then there'll be some,
some uh,
Steven,
uh,
ready Red Berg.
We'll make some fucking movie and get a bunch of awards and then the Howard
Stern of,
then we'll make the analogy like a towel you got to do,
if you want to make a fan of fucking winning award is,
makes some sad movie about the red Ed genocide.
Let me tell you,
fucking Blondie's you brownies,
you Blackie's all you fuckers black.
You said it didn't sound good.
It was talking about hair.
Oh,
Geez.
All right.
We're here to stay.
Don't ever asked him out and estimate the fucking heart of a redhead.
Okay.
That's why it Harris read that said,
burning passionate is,
it's not the devil.
It's cause we're better than you were a select few.
You know what I mean?
You know what you guys are you fucking blondes,
Brunettes,
all you and you've got,
you guys are,
you're,
you're like the fucking Ford Taurus.
You go down the highway,
there's a fucking zillion of you.
It'd be once in a while you see a Testarossa.
All right,
a nice freckled one.
Has that ever been done?
Has anybody ever been,
had a fucking swagger about being a redhead?
Um,
all right,
one last little advertisement here really quickly.
Legal zoom.com everybody.
It's national starch,
your business month@legalzoom.com.
Okay.
I know I've been talking about this from more than a month,
but so many of you are starting businesses right now.
So legal zoom has decided to stay to extend it through March,
this unbelievable offer.
Call it whatever you want just to remember.
This is a great time to start your own business.
Whether you're setting up an LLC,
an s Corp Sole Proprietorship,
or a nonprofit legal zoom takes care of you from start to finish.
They're award winning service was developed by the best legal minds in the
country,
and every business gets personalized attention.
That's why over 90% of legal zoom customers would recommend the service to their
family.
You'll be in good company,
three dozen companies of the eye,
the INC 500 list.
We're started through legal zoom.
Start Your Business right@legalzoom.com legal zoom is not a law firm and provide
self-help services at your specific direction,
but there's so much more now.
Every LLC and a corporation package includes easy to use business accounting
software,
uh,
$269 value for absolutely free.
Be sure to enter bur bur are in the referral box at checkout.
Start Your Business,
protect your family,
and safeguard your assets@legalzoom.com today.
All right.
Okay.
Back to the podcast here.
Yes.
So for the love of God,
can you people stop and just think,
you know?
All right.
You know what,
redheads,
any red heads out there listening.
Just say to them,
just go and like,
do you realize how fucking stupid you are right now?
Oh,
oh,
whatever.
Who gives a fuck?
I don't give a shit.
That's not my God.
Damn.
Cause you know what?
I can,
I can guarantee you this right now.
I'm still going to be around in 2060 and I'll be out there climbing that fucking
rope and I'll have the last bit of lead paint and as best as Outta my house.
Yeah.
And we'll see.
And then you guys be at,
well technically not ready at a more cause all you fucking hair fell out in the
shit on the side of your head is,
is white.
And that might do me in.
Now I'll be like,
oh shit.
Now fucking grab my chest,
clutched my little freckled heart and I'll keel over.
And you know what?
You know what you guys will do.
You'll fucking laugh because in your core you're a cunt.
All right.
Hey Bill.
Okay.
I want a boyfriend.
Here we go.
Oh Geez.
Here we go,
Bill.
I want a boyfriend.
Hey Bill,
I know you're pro.
You probably just read the subject and when all will drop your panties,
bitch.
Now I would never do that.
That's if you said you wanted to get laid.
Um,
so anyways,
she says that's not quite the case.
Um,
I'm a guy.
Oh,
the left turn.
The left turn.
I don't even need to read this.
Oh wait,
he's only a freshman.
I was going to say,
how was the guide?
You not know how to get a boyfriend at this point.
Have to sitcoms of are based on gay guys at this point,
aren't they?
Was that was that fucking statement?
As dumb as all redheads are going to be dead by 2060,
I don't care.
I got ahold of my fucking house.
He says,
I'm a guy,
I'm a freshman in high school and I liked guys I'd consider myself.
I consider myself average,
pretty good at sports and decent with the ladies.
He said,
I'm still in the closet.
Uh,
okay guys.
Fucking slay it.
You guys fucking it.
You know if you wanted to.
Yeah,
if you want it to,
I'm telling you,
you know what it is cause you want gotta I dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck it is.
This,
you give a fuck about clothes the way they do.
Well,
you want to watch the same shit.
That's the thing about gay guys.
You guys want to do the same shit women want to do.
So hence you are around them.
And next thing you know you're Dixon their mouth.
If I could just keep my,
if I could have just kept my fucking mouth shut,
you know,
during dirty dancing and ghosts and all those things,
I would have done much better when I was a younger man.
But whatever,
this isn't about me.
This is about Yo,
let's plow ahead.
He goes,
I go to a public school and there aren't many gays.
Well,
no,
not as far as you know.
Um,
I don't want some fabulous guy.
Just another normal guy like me.
I like that.
You don't want them to be like sit-com gay walking in a room going,
oh my God,
love that.
Are there any gay guys like that at this point?
Um,
anyways,
what advice could you give someone in my position?
Maybe your lovely girlfriend as an opinion.
Thanks bill.
I love the podcast and go fuck yourself.
You know what?
I might even call Nia in for this one.
Hang on a second.
We put this fucking thing on pause.
All right.
The lovely knee.
Everybody can you just close the door,
by the way is a fucking cause the God damn fan trying to dry off the walls.
Come over here.
We don't,
we only have one microphone.
Our Shit is all over the place,
so I don't even know where the hell the other microphone is.
Right?
All right,
so here's the deal.
I feel like it was singing backup for somebody right now.
Um,
this dude wants a boyfriend.
He's a freshman in high school.
Uh,
he's still in the closet,
laying it with the ladies.
He doesn't want some fabulous guy.
He just wants another normal guy like himself.
He said,
what advice could you give someone in his position?
Maybe your lovely girlfriend has an opinion.
Thanks,
Bill.
Loved the podcast.
Oh and go fuck yourself.
So he's in the closet,
but you want to meet a guy,
Jesus Christ.
What did I just say?
What did he just say?
I'm just trying to light taking the situation.
I mean first of all,
I feel like if you've been drinking,
you have wine on your breath,
drinking champagne and the other room,
it's four o'clock in the afternoon.
Um,
I think,
I mean I,
first of all,
I think you should maybe not necessarily come out of the closet to everyone,
but you have to sort of go where the gay is go.
And I don't mean just bars and stuff,
but there are certain like restaurants and like areas that are,
you know,
heavily given like a PowerPoint,
a PowerPoint like presentation and like you have to go where the gays go.
You should just written that down on a chalkboard thing is I think it's a little
bit problematic that you're still in the closet.
You are free to come out whenever you want to.
You shouldn't tie my timeout timeout.
But I'm saying when you're,
when you're out of the closet,
it makes it easier for you to meet other people and get into a whole little
groove and you meet people on,
they invite you places here,
there and everywhere.
And that's how you start to meet people now you can't,
when you're still in the closet,
there's going to be that secretiveness and that sort of sneaking around and
hiding and ducking and corners and you start getting the situations that you
don't want to be in as a closet,
a gay person.
Cause I feel like any gay person who's lived their life in the closet trying to
date eagerly will tell you no,
we'll tell you that it could lead to not so good situations.
So I feel like you should probably come out in a way,
or at least just start hanging out with other gay people.
I want to have to start it.
Just start playing when you're answering goes off.
Do you want me on here to answer questions?
I'm going to answer it the way I answered them.
I don't need you to tell me when.
I don't need anybody telling me how to answer him.
Snap,
snap,
snap asked me to come in here.
If you're just getting to like micromanage how I answer the question,
what is wrong with you?
You know,
you're an angry drunk.
Not try a couple of glasses of champagne.
You turn it into an asshole.
I don't think you should come out.
Not as a freshman for fuck sakes.
People as such,
assholes.
You know what I mean?
I think he should just,
I think you should go find some other college.
He's a freshman in high school.
Oh,
in high school.
You know,
fucking just ride it out.
Fight some other gay kids.
Hang out with them.
Play baseball down at the,
uh,
the gay baseball park.
And uh,
and then once you become a,
you keep watching,
you know what you need to do,
you've got to lead your fucking town behind.
Then you move to a shitty does your high school and not have towards city.
Let me finish my ignorance.
Don't move to a city.
They'll have the gay,
the gay part of town.
Well,
no,
it's got to be over because a lot of the high schools that have abs shut up.
A lot of more progressive high schools.
They'll have like an LGBT,
you know,
club or something like that.
Oh,
he obviously doesn't have that already.
We'd fucking join it.
He went,
he's going to high school.
Like I went to high school,
you know,
get back on.
Right.
It's a fucking meathead school.
That's what's going on with him.
Those morons aren't going to understand them.
Why,
why go through extra fucking pain?
The great thing is he knows who he is and he knows the direction he's going.
You're going to be fine.
Uh,
I would say try and stay in shape because you are trying to appeal to a bunch of
guys and we're all fucking,
uh,
you know,
I just don't want him to start crotch trolling around online.
Getting sucked into some seedy situations.
These were older guys are going to take advantage of themselves because he's
young and in the closet and he's very,
you know,
he doesn't quite know what to do.
I just,
I'm worried that he's going to get sucked into that type of shit as oppose to
trying to find peers where you're all sort of going through it together.
That's why I was encouraging to come out of the closet or to at least maybe
start affiliating if your,
if your high school has one of those LGBT clubs or whatever,
you know,
that way you,
you feel less alone so you're less likely to,
like I say go online and get sucked into some weird head trip sexual abuse
situation dude.
Cause there's nothing like an older and know that an older Predator will love
more than a young confused.
I'm still in the closet.
Wait a minute now not.
So you're saying older gay guys are predators and saying there are older people
who will prey on the young,
young,
well listen,
50 year old guys will try and bang an 18 year old chicks.
So why would,
why would it so what he's saying,
we're all pieces of shit.
What kind of hatred or you spewing,
I'm just saying I want to bring the world together.
He is in a very precarious situation and if you start going down that road where
you're just sneaking around so much,
you can get caught up into some bad shit.
And I don't want some older guys and Oh shit,
he's getting blown by fucking chicks.
This guys killing.
It's like he's hitting it from both sides of the plate.
So are you buying?
No,
he's still in the closet,
but he's killing it with the ladies.
Well you need to stop that right now.
I know he doesn't cut fam.
It's just going to be another chapter in the book.
I think you're going to be fine,
sir.
The Nia,
they his podcast.
It's on its way.
Everyone on Twitter.
I know you guys have been asking me for weeks.
What's going on with the podcast?
What's happening is I'm also rebuild.
Are you fighting with your record label?
What's going on?
Why is this project keeping delayed now?
I'm rebuilding my website right now and it's got my films on and it's got some
writing.
That's your podcast.
Rome is underwater.
My podcast room is under water.
My sanctuary is destroyed,
but that's why it's taking so long.
So bear with me you guys,
but you should do,
you should do a podcast underwater in a flooded room.
Just like Kanye West.
He had a busted jaw.
He still went in the studio.
All right.
All right,
well listen,
we were just fucking around there.
I think the great thing is that you already know who you are,
so you're going to end up where you want to be.
Um,
that age is really isn't easy for,
for anybody.
But uh,
I will tell you this,
all of all the fucking bullshit.
She said she's right about those creepy old gay guys looking for a young,
confused young man out there.
You know,
you're better than that.
All right?
You got to ask some standard no white chest hair.
Beat it.
Old pubes
Alrighty.
Plowing ahead.
What do we got here?
Dilemma.
Hey Bill,
would you rather be permanently invisible under the condition that inanimate
objects you've touched also become invisible Jesus Christ?
Or would you want to be able to shape shift into anyone or anything in the
world?
But you have to stay that way for 24 hours.
Oh,
without a doubt,
shape shift.
I mean,
how long they would it be if I was invisible and everything I touched became
invisible,
I wouldn't want to do that.
You know
what?
I want to do that.
How could I bring down these fucking international bankers if I was invisible
that can make inanimate shit invisible.
Oh,
that's what I would do.
I touch a bunch of guns and given to the regular people and have them go down to
one of those fucking devil's islands meetings.
Um,
no,
I wouldn't do that shit.
No,
I'd be a shape shifter.
Now the real question is,
who would you shape shift into Troy Aikman?
You know,
I'd commentated game right out of the back,
you know,
right out of the gate to see if people could notice.
I have,
I have some of those gloves that he has.
You know this,
I'm an adult guy.
Gloves.
Now,
the ones Dan Marino used to sell,
I got one of those long.
It's wintertime coach and sometimes I wear a suit,
you know,
kind of coach.
I could stand there with fucking ear muffs on,
uh,
what would I sound like him?
Who would I shape shift into?
It's a fucking weird one.
Okay.
Oh,
I,
you know what,
I couldn't handle that power because that basically if you could shape shift,
all you'd have to do is shape shift into any girl you ever wanted to fuck
whoever she's fucking,
you just shape shift into that person.
You just come walking through the door.
Hello.
You know,
with some flowers.
Oh my God,
I'd be the first person brought up.
Now what kind of rape would that be?
The shape shift and rapist,
you know?
And then they'd have to somehow,
how would they stop me from shape,
shifting myself into the foreman of the jury to say,
we the jury final,
Billy rape is red phase,
not guilty on all charges.
After that Big Jake is Christ.
Um,
oh,
there'll be in a shape shifter would be great,
man.
You could freak the fucking
world out.
You know,
it'd be great if some like huge leader of the world was,
was given a speech and you somehow got behind them.
And we're also on TV jumping up and down,
you know,
like somebody who painted that face except you look just like the guy giving the
speech,
you know,
oh,
that could be endless fucking fun.
How would I handle shape shifting?
Ah,
Jesus.
That'd be a lot of conversations with a higher power with that one.
You know,
like when you drink and then you get sick and like,
ah,
God,
I swear to God,
I'm never gonna do that again.
Just let me get through this.
I swear to God and we to clean up my fucking act.
Like what do you say to God after you just shape,
shifted into your neighbor and fucked his wife?
God,
if you can find it in your heart.
I mean,
technically,
you know,
she doesn't know.
She's none the wiser.
And uh,
I know it was rock and uh,
I'll say a couple of hail,
hail Mary's.
I promise I will not shape shift into anybody today.
That's all.
I mean,
I know some of that's one of the things when a,
after I died and God's given me that you go into hell,
look,
now I'm just going to be like,
dude,
I mean,
come on.
I could shape shift.
All right.
Half the people on Earth can't even handle becoming a bouncer without being a
Douche.
I could shape shift.
What'd you think I was going to turn into fucking Ronald Mcdonald's and push
some kid on a swing.
All right.
Okay.
There was some hotties that lived on my block and uh,
some other guys got to him before I did and I should have been man enough to
accept that.
But you know,
I had this,
uh,
get out of jail free card so I shape shifted it to them when they were a away on
business.
Then I would just come home,
surprise home a day early
and then I fucked him and then I left and then I let her deal with the weirdness
the next day when her husband came home,
when he came home a day later,
hey,
hello,
how are you?
What do you mean your home?
Where where,
where are you?
Yeah.
I thought you were just in the bedroom and then he's like,
what the fuck's going on?
Jesus Christ.
You know something?
I thought they had made every porno that you could make this.
That's a whole new shape shift and porn shape shifting porn.
Discovered right here on the Monday morning podcast.
Um,
all right,
what the fuck else am I getting it?
That's all the emails I had this week.
That's all I got.
Oh,
for fuck sakes.
You know what?
You know something.
Don't want to seem worse.
I didn't watch any fucking hockey this week.
I watched nothing.
I didn't even get to enjoy the fucking Boston Bruins winning street in nothing.
Sean Thornton beaten the shit out of that fucking Rinaldo guy.
Whatever the hell his name is.
I missed all of that.
I missed all that cause I was,
I
was on the road again chicka boom chicka boom,
boom,
boom.
You know,
it was a great gig too.
I did the Fountain Street Church for laugh fest out in grand rapids,
Michigan.
And what was phenomenal about that was a,
I got to perform in a church.
I got to go up on the pulpit,
give a little speech.
I had a great time.
You know,
it's amazing,
isn't it?
Reminded me of Old Tiger Stadium.
MMM.
Because Old Tiger stadium was one of the few stadiums that the only stadium
major league that had an upper deck that went all the way around and this church
had an upper deck that went,
yeah,
all the way around the church from one side of the altar all the way to the
other.
And then the altar was up there.
And uh,
I don't know,
made me feel like I was in an old ballpark.
All right,
let me see here.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Here we go.
Ah,
Shit.
You know what I'm doing right now?
I'm trying to,
I'm like,
so I can fill out the rest of this podcast.
I'm looking for a,
okay.
I'm looking for emails.
This isn't good.
This isn't good to be doing on a live podcast.
Somebody texted me,
you think Bonham is good.
Could he do this in six inch?
An a six inch stiletto.
Alright.
Oh,
Sheila e.
Yes,
she Lee.
He kills it.
I still think I still think bond was better than Sheila e come on.
You know,
plus John Bonham was,
he was sort of a fashion Easter.
Used to wear those silly little boots all the time.
He could still fucking,
he could still kill it.
What does it with everybody always trying to fucking fall?
I guess he's the benchmark,
right?
Um,
although Sheila is to shit.
Okay.
All right,
here we go.
I find an email.
I'm just going to start randomly reading these right now.
Hey Bill,
I'm an avid fan of your podcast.
As I listened to it every Monday with my chemistry Tuta who is now a fan of
yours as well.
Well,
Jesus,
you guys aren't getting anything done.
Are you?
Um,
I have a question to ask and forgive me if I give you a history lesson,
but this is something I want to get off my chest.
Holy Fuck.
Is this along?
Ah,
come on people.
Try not to get things off your chest.
You know how bad I read.
All right,
let's give it a shot.
You know what the first thing I'm gonna do want to make it lodge Ya.
All right?
It's kind of personal for me,
but you as a man might understand,
and I'm not saying a woman would understand better because she probably would
never understand it.
All my problem,
I am a loner and I have always been.
I relate to that serve 100%.
We are on the same page.
I never made any friends as a kid and I was abandoned by everyone.
I knew that right now.
You just went into the fucking,
now you sound like you're written.
Um,
now what does it Hans Christian Anderson,
what's the name of that guy who wrote a that toy story?
What the fuck is it called?
They're a Christmas story.
Christmas Carol Christian,
Christian Laettner and I can't fucking thing ghost of Christmas cast part too.
Anyways,
I don't know anything about my family members because their name besides your
name and job title.
Over the years I started to hate everybody.
I came into contact with every person I met.
I'd be condescending towards and I was indifferent towards everyone I met a few
years ago.
I had this girl try and become my friend,
which is weird because since I keep to myself and nobody bothers me,
but all of a sudden this girl comes up to me and starts asking about who I am.
I of course,
tell it a fuck off
Jesus Christ.
Dude.
He goes,
I told her to fuck off and I'm cold and indifferent.
You're not indifferent.
You have a definite feeling towards her.
Fuck off.
Uh,
she rode the same bus I wrote and she tried to make conversation with me a lot,
but still I was just telling you to fuck off,
but not in those exact words.
Okay.
All right.
But,
uh,
I told her to go talk to someone.
Who cares,
dude,
how old are you?
Every time I looked at her,
she always smiled at me.
The smile was the most amazing smile I've ever seen in my life.
If a smile was a super,
yeah,
you fucking had a crush on her for smile was a super powered be hers and I
couldn't help but melt a bit.
Every time I saw her smile,
Jesus Christ,
to what's going on here.
Few years ago I got into every,
I got everyone in the school coming up to up to me asking who I was.
A few years later,
it turns out that she was asking everybody about me for two years and nobody
could tell her anything about me.
So now she has gotten the whole school interested in me and finding out who I
am.
Dude,
is this like a fantasy or did this really happen?
Do you wear like a leather jacket and ride a motorcycle?
Um,
they never learned anything about me.
Now that I'm in college,
I'm starting to see her everywhere.
If Joe can you just fucked this girl,
I'd take her up for a malt already.
Come on,
man.
Did is a critical part of your life.
You're young,
this girl's cute.
You're still,
you're drafted in the first round.
You don't want to wait too long.
You wait too long to fucking find a mate.
All of a sudden you know,
you,
you're trying to find some fucking once in a lifetime,
six round pick,
you know,
like a Tom Brady.
It's not out there.
Um,
he goes,
wait.
Anyways,
when we actually meet,
it's awkward and she just stares at me uncomfortable.
He then runs away.
I don't know why this happens to me whenever I think I see what,
I don't know why this happens to me.
Whenever I think I see here are actually running to her.
Is there something wrong with me?
Why am I going through this weird bouts of fight or flight mode?
Do it because you were fucking abandoned by everyone around you,
which hurt you as a kid.
So now you're trying to fucking wall yourself off.
You should fucking talk to that girl.
Just tell us.
Say,
listen,
you got to understand I'm a psycho.
I didn't have anybody in my life.
I don't know how to do this,
but when you smile at me,
I almost fall out of my chair.
Kate,
can you handle the fact that I'm socially
a little far behind?
My peers and with that would you like to go see a movie?
Okay.
And then every time you feel like sabotaging it just,
I dunno.
I Dunno dude.
That's,
that's you.
You're going to have to undo like 20 years of Shit.
It sounds like.
I don't know if you can do,
if you could do this,
uh,
you know,
in one week,
like those dumb doctor Phil shows you need to come out of your shell and
everybody claps and then you go and like the guy's supposed to be fixed.
It's going to take awhile.
But Dude,
you know something.
Yeah,
you should definitely go after this girl if you fail and stuff like that,
you should definitely do it.
And uh,
she sounds like she's,
you know,
socially uncomfortable too.
So you know,
you can help her,
she can help you,
both of you guys,
you get a little more outgoing.
Next thing you know.
Yeah,
you might,
you might have something there and if not,
at the very least going through that experience with her,
we'll give you a couple at bats.
So when the right one comes along,
you'll know what to do.
All right.
There you go.
Good luck to you sir.
Um,
all right.
What are we up to here?
Oh,
49 minutes.
It's fucking drag.
And I'm sorry guys.
This is why I never do podcasts.
When I fly,
I stink.
Okay.
I,
I never should do podcasts when I fly out and come home and there's a fucking
hole in my ceiling.
All right.
Is that bad?
Oh,
here's one.
Hey Bill,
you're being ripped off.
There's a video out there called steak in a Bj date.
No.
You know what?
I ripped them off.
I actually read about it and I forgot.
I read about it and I said that this should be staking a blowjob day.
This is right there is why I don't watch other comedians acts because shit just
flies into your head throughout the course of years and years and years.
Then all of a sudden somebody asks a question,
he give the answer and you think it's yours and it's not,
um,
steak and a blow job that did not come up with that.
Somebody else came up with that,
so I am not,
I am not offended.
This is like you guys listening to me.
Just read my junk mail.
This is now what's going on right now.
Could somebody please explain to me how the fuck and Montreal Canadians are in
first place?
How do those cops suck in this still good?
You just at this point,
you just have to give it up to that franchise.
They just a good fucking French I,
but you know something.
The fucking Pittsburgh Penguins,
Pittsburgh Penguins.
All of a sudden they're coming on.
You know what?
Those motherfuckers,
those motherfuckers,
they always,
Dale like every time they went from Mario Lemieux,
then they got yarn mill yard,
right?
Then they had a little bit of a lull there.
Then they get old rosy red lips and they get Gino,
and then they also had fucking,
what's his face that they just traded to the hurricanes?
Yeah.
I can't think of anybody's fucking name.
And then you think like,
okay,
that's it.
It's over.
Right?
How many fucking times?
They're like the fucking hockey version of the New York Yankees from the 1920s
to the 50s where it was Ruth Gehrig to Dimaggio to mantle.
That's what they're doing in hockey.
I Dunno,
this is my thing.
As long as the Montreal Canadians continue to suffer in the curse of Patrick Wa,
you know,
and they know it's occurs.
That's why they tried to make friends with them again,
because they realized after they booed him out of the city that he went to
fucking Colorado and started when and I'm going,
they're like,
we don't know need him or her home.
We asked see material,
see blue block K ru's right.
They didn't give a fuck.
Now they give a fuck.
Now all of a sudden they're asking them,
hey,
yeah,
you know,
we're kind of,
uh,
you know,
we will.
Sorry,
fucking phenomenal.
And every year that goes by more month old Montreal Canadien fans die and less
of them know what it's like to win a cup.
And I'm going to tell you,
I fucking love it.
You know what I love about Montreal Canadians fans?
You know what they say to me now?
They bring up Gila floor.
That's how far in the past.
Anything great happening between them and the Bruins are they go fucking ape
shit when they beat us now in the regular season.
You understand they owned us gala floor.
Fuck Gigga floors scored that goal before I even watched my first fucking hockey
game.
I don't know how old you people think I am.
That was like the late seventies
I was too busy recovering from being hit by a car.
I had enough to recover.
I get two days off from school.
I do remember that it happened on a Wednesday and the guy said,
all right,
you know what?
You shouldn't go to school Thursday,
Friday.
And I was fucking psyched going for once.
I don't have to fake sick.
And I sat there and I watched cartoons and I with a little spoon hate with a
little spoon cause the bumper hit me right on the side of the head.
I've done this before in the podcast.
Put,
put two fingers right on the side of your head,
right.
And then bite down on your molar suit,
your back teeth there.
You feel that thing that goes in and out.
That's right where I got hit.
So it hurt to chew.
So I had to eat with a little spoon for two days and I couldn't go to school
of the greatest things to ever happen to me.
This is CJ seven,
I believe.
Um,
big fucking guy getting out of it.
Oh my God.
I hit him by,
Ooh,
I totally fucking drove right into the guy.
I didn't look.
I thought I looked is another guy.
St Stake and Bj Day,
uh,
um,
is spreading.
This had nothing to do with me.
It had nothing to do.
Not thing.
It's not mine.
It's somebody else's.
All right,
here we go.
Last thing I'm going to read and that's going to mercifully be the end of this
uh,
podcast.
Bill thought this might interest you.
It's an article about divorce.
This guy's an illustrator.
Tough road to Hoe I am to three years and still no settlement.
The guys broke as a result and has stopped producing work in hopes that the
parasitic x we'll give in once there's no cashflow.
Oh.
And the guy is for Digi prodigiously good as a painter.
Yeah.
You know,
I take,
I actually have faith in some of these divorce settlements that,
um,
I think in the near future there's going to be way more.
Okay.
Way More light shined on these things.
And uh,
eventually it's,
it's gonna,
it's gonna come around,
you know?
Okay.
Can't that be a,
I,
I just,
I don't get that,
that shit where you can just,
it's,
it's just too one sided with one person could just live off the other person.
I've talked about all this shit a zillion fucking times,
haven't I?
You know,
that whole shit where,
uh,
the woman starts dating a new guy,
but she won't let the guy move in because their last guy made more money.
So then the two of them just sit there living off the fucking first guy.
You know?
You don't think that's fucked up.
Well,
I do.
Um,
all right.
You know what people I tried,
I tried to,
I,
you know,
I did my best.
I tried,
tried to do a podcast.
Um,
I think that's it.
Saint Cole's water damage hockey.
Small towns.
Eating like a cunt.
Yeah,
I got to stop doing that guys.
I've really let myself fucking,
ah,
it's weird.
I look good with a shirt on,
but with a shirt off,
it's not a,
it's not a good thing.
Like my chest is 35,
but my fucking,
what the fuck is this?
Is this going to be another guy telling me and I got a [inaudible].
All right.
This is only gonna be 55 minutes this week.
People,
I apologize.
I'll give you an update next week.
You know what?
I owe you guys five minutes and you will get those five minutes next week.
Okay?
That's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
Um,
I'll talk to you next week.